our helpful advice with Bobby and kalila
weapons of mass destruction hi Bob and
kalila I'm an eighteen year old guy that
dropped out of high school recently to
become an artist yes yeah my day job is
waiting tables at a bar and at night I
make my art I'm short and Filipino yes
they go hand in hand
recently I googled the average Filipino
dick size and that made me feel a lot
better about myself
my question is since I have literally no
social status wealth height or dick to
cling on to I don't even know how to
start with approaching girls since Bobby
is two feet tall and has a Korean penis
how do guys like us get [ __ ] PS Jorge
has a pink dick what a question okay
his name is Bryce Bryce I have done I
have done excellently was that word I
like it though excellently I've done
I've dated all kinds of women women that
I wasn't supposed to get kalila and I
should not be dating on just looks alone
based on looks God made her for a
superstar like soccer player or George
Clooney not name but the couple like a
kid but I got I got her boom because I
believed that I'm them my dick it's my
uncle [ __ ] cuz it works and I put it
inside for you take it
oh I don't put it inside my dick is to
put inside things and I put it inside
many magical places including my ear
hole yeah and I slip it I stay and I
stick it in things and I take it out and
I laugh and I run away call that sex and
I call it sex all right so it's like
dude you're young do good art the pain
and suffering that you feel is what's
gonna make you a better artist so feel
that pain and suffering and but your
dick has nothing to do with it you
[ __ ] idiot
it really doesn't it doesn't at all it
doesn't have anything to do with it I
was like him in always something I kept
like freaking out I got my dick my dick
but what is in it's in also yours
than high five I mean I'm just I've just
never been a girl that enjoyed like
massive penises anyways anything above a
seven and a half is just way too much
for me I can't handle it's not
pleasurable for me some women like it I
have friends who just love to be plowed
by anything you know long and wide but
not me well if you like a solid five hit
me up oh you're five inches no that
wasn't the problem
he's from proposition me to have to say
no I did I said not you in general oh
you just did that to my girl I know look
at my eyes oh my god you looked me right
in the eyes Gilbert not them not the
weapon of mass discretion bro bro hey
we're friends
we're friends Justin what's up I will
apologize trick because I don't want
[ __ ] on my face you got a babe good job
don't look me in the eye again five
inches I was offering it to the other
Asian women all right I kind of got a
piece so bad I'm so sorry about that but
not really it's poo smells though I
think you're fine just wash your jacket
I get pinkeye just all over my body
yeah even in my eyes yeah all right
Bobby
[Music]